Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so this is going
to be in explainer for the new Jedi order
that's rising up in the Bendu if you never
heard that term Bendu or Dai Bendu is the
original name of the George Lucas had for
the Jedi in his rough draft for the first
Star Wars movie now.
A lot of things change with the new films
as well as Star Wars rebels are going back
to those ideas so he did know, I'm doing Star
Wars Fridays for the rest of time.
There is a new Star Wars giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
two IMAX gift certificates.
So we talked a lot about the last Jedi as
in the Jedi order is done something new is
coming in both Kylo Ren and Rey Luke is seeking
the truth of things at the original Jedi Temple
and if you've heard or you've read the original
rough draft of Star Wars by George Lucas you
hear about something called the die Bendu
the original name of the Jedi have a character
on Star Wars rebels the season called the
Bendu who is based on that idea the truer
interpretation of the force in both the Jedi
order the Sith or any other dark side force
user.
You may have heard about the rebels Easter
eggs that appear during Star Wars Rogue one
like the ghost ship or general Hera they try
to be very consistent with the mythology through
the animated series the books that the writing
right now the expanded material in the saga
films most of the time that's for continuity's
sake, but in this case it's in the nature
of the force in the direction that the new
trilogy is going with it.
She had this idea that the trying to move
past these old traditions the tradition of
the Jedi order the tradition of the Sith the
first time we meet the Bendu character on
rebels he helps Kanan see the truth of things
like he sees what he wants to see the Bendu
tries to get him to see the real truth.
So here's that clip the tea that up, you have
your imbalance will promote some balance.
Your presence is like of violence will and
disquiet will force will but you will not
a Jedi it was really a program like all I'm
the one in the middle while to check it is
noted that picture has been my experience
because you do not see them see them for what
they are asked me fear reached think that's
how they see the till I see myself sidetrip
to so imagine Rey getting a version of those
types of lessons from Luke Skywalker Luke
Skywalker sort of the Kanan of the saga films.
Presumably he's learn those things.
So he's passing this on to Rey.
She can become the first of this new order
you can call them Jedi you can call them die
Bendu you can call them Bendu they might attach
a name to them in the new trilogy but my bet
is is that it will be very close to the idea
of been do it all signs point that they're
moving back to this base then do where the
original idea of the Jedi started from when
a practical way all the characters are going
back to the original ideas about the Jedi
and in a meadow way the writers the producers
the people that make Star Wars are going back
to the original ideas so if you haven't been
watching rebels you don't absolutely have
to.
But they do cover a lot of very cool ideas
based on what the Bendu teaches them in the
context of the animated series the been do
helps Ezra and Kanan balance themselves in
the force, so you have to imagine the light
side, the dark side on the other balance being
in the middle.
So in pursuit of that they do a lot of really
cool stuff like trying to combine Jedi and
Sith Hall of prawns like he warns them that
doing so will give them this ultimate knowledge.
It comes at a price.
So you have to think of it in the way that
you think of Anakin's force visions.
So he's very powerful.
He has force visions, but the path those visions
lead him on becomes this very self-destructive
self fulfilling prophecy until his ultimate
redemption at the end of episode six.
So this is what Snoke and Luke Skywalker trying
to do find balance in the force Snoke has
a slightly more nefarious approach to what
he's trying to turn Kylo Ren into this ultimate
balance Bendu Jedi but Luke is trying to do
the same thing with Rey and you can imagine
that you know just based on the way the narrative
moves that they'll slowly reach this balance
enlightenment around the same time before
whatever epic battle.
They end up having so is much as this is a
story of the last Jedi.
It's also the story of the first of the new
Jedi, we can call them the new Jedi as shorthand,
but really Bendu would probably be more appropriate
or even die Bendu if you really want to go
back to the origins.
So if you don't of the story of the original
rough draft.
It's actually pretty fascinating, most of
you probably know that the character we know
is Luke Skywalker used to be called Anakin
star killer his father was named Kanan star
killer who asked general Luke Skywalker.
This is the rough draft remember son, it sounds
a little confusing to train his son.
So when the original rough draft Luke Skywalker
was general could know be so that change to
Luke Skywalker being the protagonist his father
was still a cyborg, but he became Darth Vader
so they kept that idea in the general Luke
Skywalker from the rough draft became the
Obi-Wan Kenobi character the opening conflict
wasn't so much the death Star plans as it
was this transition of power between the nights
of the Sith in the Jedi Bendu order in the
Galactic Republic.
Lucas referred to that opening conflict is
the great Jedi rebellion.
So that wasn't quite as much Galactic politics
going on, it was more of a Jedi centric story,
but there's this really important quote from
that rough draft that gives you an idea for
what's going on in the new trilogy Kanan star
killer is talking to general Skywalker are
saying take my son he's talking about Anakin
star killer the Jedi Bendu must survive we
must pass it on only a Jedi can stop the Empire
were very old a new generation of Jedi must
be started take him teach them the way of
the Jedi Bendu if that idea sounds familiar
is because during the force awakens when we
meet Rey people like Luke Skywalker the Jedi
just a myth she doesn't know what it is to
be force sensitive she's only heard stories
about what happened this is about 30 years
after the original trilogy and, so it's been
a long time in the Empire in the first order
after them.
Basically ran a smear campaign against Luke
Skywalker blaming all of the problems on him.
Everything was going great there was economic
prosperity to Luke Skywalker came along and
ruined it all for us.
So imagine the worst kind of Galactic yellow
journalism just smearing him all over the
tabloids.
So Luke goes to find the true origins of the
Jedi.
While this is going on.
So nobody believes in the Jedi anymore.
We need a new order to rise up.
We don't know exactly how Snoke is going to
be training Kylo Ren, but you have to imagine
that there's going to be some parity between
their lessons the be learning some of the
same things from slightly different perspectives.
But listen to Obi-Wan's original speech to
Luke Skywalker about what the force is the
force the forces of the Jedi is all in energy
field created by all living things surrounds
us in the trickster binds the galaxy together.
The important thing to remember here is that
Obi-Wan has already learned to create force
goes he's ready learned that lesson.
So he has a more complete picture of what
the forces he's not just talking about the
light side of the force.
The force flows through Jedi through every
living thing, so that's going to be really
important for Rey's training deepening her
connection with all living things with the
planet with the animals with the rocks the
trees.
The way that Yoda talks to Luke about how
it just flows through everything so I don't
want to talk too much about rumors from behind
the scenes but there have been some stories
from the set the some of her training montage
moments will play out in funny ways based
on that idea her trying to attune herself
with the nature of that island there and that
planet the let me know in the comments what
you think about the idea of Kylo Ren and Rey
becoming been do in the new trilogy as opposed
to just being Jedi or dark Jedi or Sith or
just a more powerful version of the nights
of rent.
The way they explain the nights of rent and
I'll do a separate video about this is that
there really just the new thing to replace
the Sith, so there still very much dark side
force users.
If you have any requests for other Star Wars
bonus videos episode eight or any the other
films.
Just leave them in the comments below.
Remember that Fridays are now Star Wars video
days till the end of time.
So there's all kinds of stuff that we have
to talk about what's going to happen next
is is there's a video that I want to do about
Chewbacca Kylo Ren and the idea of his life
that and how he's going to resolve it.
So that'll probably be my next Star Wars video,
but congratulations to the new giveaway winner
Scott Sansome you win two IMAX gift certificates.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner when I post
that next Star Wars video that will probably
be on Monday or Tuesday.
While you wait for that to post you can click
here to learn all about Snoke's Backstory
in episode 8 and you can click here to learn
about the guardians that are going to be appearing
during avengers infinity war thank you so
much for watching everbody high five I'll
see you in the next video!